while bringing life to the arts district
a local artist is bringing
vibrant designs and some of the
businesses in the district of downtown
las vegas
connor fatou azam grew up in south
africa but now
makes a living as a graphic designer
here in las vegas and through hand
lettering the artist is helping shape
the look
and vibes with his murals we're trying
to
to really bring the arts district up and
and get the culture out there and
there's a lot of artists that that do a
lot of amazing things here
and yeah so i'm just happy to contribute
to that
creating is has always been a passion of
mine it
it really gives me a sense of
accomplishment and to
to to create something out of thin air
and
really be proud of the work that you've
done the grind that you that you've
put into it it's really it's about
it's more so about the journey than the
destination
he also had the unique opportunity to
create a large backdrop that stood
behind former vice president joe biden
when he was on
campaign stop in henderson last week